Owen Wilson and Adrian Brody in the same
movie noses that I have seen today
Midnight in Paris is directed by Woody
Allen and stars Owen Wilson Rachel
McAdams and a whole bunch of great stars
for me Woody Allen is very off and on so
I'm nice to make a great movie sometimes
I make a bad movie sometimes I'll make
an okay movie and then everyone so I'll
just turn on a classic and it's so
strange how he's so inconsistent but he
is world renowned famous for making very
quirky comedies good romances and being
a great writer in general Marion Cottle
are gosh I don't know how to say her
name
go ahead comment you know you want to so
almost implies that writer in this film
who's on vacation in Paris with his
fiancee Rachel McAdams and he starts to
enjoy taking these midnight strolls
through Paris to basically get away from
his fiancee who is one of the most
loathsome female characters I have seen
in film recently and one of these nights
he decides to get a taxicab that passes
by him at the stroke of midnight and we
get out of the taxi cab he walks into
this restaurant and he's suddenly
transported into the 1920s he meets
Ernest Hemingway Pablo Picasso and all
these really famous people and he's like
wow what is going on
I'm in the 20s I'm Owen Wilson and he
starts to really enjoy the company of
this girl Miriam and each night he keeps
coming back and gets transported in the
20s and he wakes up he's back in his
time of course everyone doesn't believe
him and you know he's Owen Wilson and
he's like wow I really really enjoyed
Midnight in Paris I was very surprised
at how quirky and funny this film was
and how likable Owen Wilson's character
especially was because he gets crapped
on by his fiancee and he just takes it
all like a man and his stride doesn't
get all you know flustered and then he
goes at night he goes to this air that
he loves one of the big messages of this
film I really agreed with and relate to
and I just thought it was told
beautifully see Owen Wilson in the 2000s
he
he can't stop thinking about the 20s and
when he actually gets a chance to go
there everyone in the 20s thanks to the
late 1800s is a golden age and and he's
like he's like no no the 20s that's
where it happened as he keeps going to
these different eras he's discovering
that everyone in that era thinks that
the past was better and everyone likes
living in the past they like the idea of
the past more than the present and
that's kind of how it is today because
think about it everyone who's my age in
their mid 20s or so thanks like the 90s
the late 80s was the greatest time and
all the games and we're better the
cartoons then were better all the kids
today think their cartoons are better
the kids in the future will think their
cartoons are better but we'll think that
the ones in the past or better this film
tells that beautifully and it's so true
Owen Wilson is just great in this movies
funny Rachel McAdams is very good at
being this terrible the romantic
elements of the film are so sweet that
his core was just a really well-written
romantic comedy very funny and very
enjoyable I'm going to give it three and
a half out of four stars
I really enjoyed midnight in Paris